mohammed bashir fled his home in kobani
to escape islamic state
since then he's been smoking up to 80
cigarettes a day to cope with the stress
he often comes to this hill on turkey's
border with syria
to look over kobani
mohammed says he'd be smoking and
drinking if alcohol were available
he just wants to forget what's happened
and feel nothing
he says he's angry islamic state is
destroying his country
in front of his eyes
they are murdering stealing taking
everything
here
mohammed points out the restaurant where
he used to work as a chef
the building has been destroyed
we hear gunfire but there is no way to
tell which side it's coming from
muhammad asks the others but they don't
know either
muhammad says he wants to join the fight
but can't because he has young children
his oldest son is still fighting in
kabbani but muhammad had to leave
he brought his family to the turkish
border town of suraj
six weeks ago they were given shelter in
one of the five refugee camps in suruc
more than 5 000 people live in these
hastily built tents
without running water or electricity
lives in this tent with his wife salwa
and eight of his children
salwa says she'd like to offer us tea
but at the moment there's no water
the youngest of muhammad and salwa's
children is just three years old
the parents have had to explain the
harsh realities of their situation to
her
as well
she's told the children that there's a
war going on in kobani
but she says they still ask her why they
can't return
she tells them no there's fighting back
home and islamic state is there
talking about home makes her think about
her 19 year old son ayub
he's still fighting in kobani salwa
doesn't even have a photograph of him
is all she can say
a truck arrives with blankets the nights
are already cold in the tents without
any heating
one man complains that he hasn't got
enough for his family muhammad and salwa
stay out of the dispute
muhammad says it's hard it feels like
begging
before the conflict he had a house and
everything that goes with it
standing here she's embarrassed
finally they receive their blankets but
they only get three
too little for a family of ten
we want to know how aid supplies are
organized so we head to the city centre
suraj is governed by turkish kurds
it's a city of 100 000 currently hosting
some
sixty thousand refugees
people have been flooding into the city
for six weeks
more arrive every day elmes has taken
responsibility for the care and
accommodation the refugees receive
she set up a warehouse for humanitarian
aid in an old factory
most of the supplies were donated by the
kurdish community
the provisions they've collected so far
won't be enough to last the winter
they need better tents heating supplies
food and medicines
put simply they need everything
organizing the process is a logistical
nightmare
the city doesn't have the resources to
cope with the crisis
says only the kurdish community has
supported them so far
before they were financing 20 000 meals
a day
now it's just 10 000. they're having to
split the portions to provide for
everyone
and they only have four vehicles to
distribute the goods
they need help from the international
community elmes is constantly looking
for support
as we're driving she receives a phone
call telling her an austrian delegation
is waiting in her office
the delegation wants to learn about the
situation in kobani
they're joined by a group of journalists
sees a chance to gain international
support
she inquires about aid supplies for the
refugees
and at the same time brings up the issue
of kurdish
independence and why kobani cannot be
allowed to fall
is very important to the kurds if it
falls their 40-year struggle for
independence will have been for nothing
all the victims the arrests all the
suffering she says the fight may go on
for a long time
but the kurds won't abandon kobani
elmes gets constant updates on the
fighting it's a day of mixed feelings
for her
more kurds have been killed in battles
on this day
five men died in the fighting none were
older than 30.
this man says his blood is boiling with
rage they've come here to honor the
young people who have died
this woman asks what islamic state wants
from them and why they want to repress
them
burn their homes down and take their
money she says they claim to be fighting
for islam but they're not muslims
they're infidels
this graveyard was set aside for victims
of the fighting
the sadness here is mixed with anger at
the turkish government
people here feel ankara has done little
to save the city
elmes doesn't want to accept that turkey
will only allow injured
people to cross its border people here
say even those helping is troops will be
allowed to enter turkey
elmer says whatever she does won't be
enough she gives the refugees food and
cares for them
but she still has a guilty conscience
she says if she were asked
she'd like to go to kirbani and fight
herself
we head back to the warehouse to meet
the bashir family again
fourteen-year-old doesn't want to join
the game
she misses her home
she says if she were in kobani she'd be
at her uncle's house
playing with her cousins and friends
their talk listen to music and study
together
we ask her what she misses most
she says listening to music and watching
tv
there's some good news for the children
though soon a makeshift school is due to
open here in the warehouse
they're excited at the thought of going
back to school
at 7 pm the food rations are handed out
muhammad collects them for the family he
receives rice
soup and mandarins enough for everyone
like his daughter he thinks about what
he'd be doing in kirbani right now
cooking in his restaurant
for the time being he and his wife don't
want to think about starting a new life
in turkey
salva says willing she'd return to
kabani soon and finally see her son
again
muhammad says when he returns home he'll
smile again for the first time
his son will get married and they'll
celebrate with him
kurdish forces have been bolstered by
the arrival of peshmerga fighters from
iraq
the refugees take that as a positive
sign
tomorrow mohammed will return to his
spot on the border
and look over the town he hopes will
soon be liberated
foreign